[Music]
let's play a game against matt holmes
okay
so i'm going to play an opening which i
have played my whole life
the king's indian defense as with every
new opening that i play
i will explain the basics behind this
opening after the game i simply do not
have the time to do it now
but basically as i've already explained
before the king's indian is what's
called a hyper modern opening where you
allow
your opponent to control the center and
then you attack that center from a
distance
with some of your pieces now h4 is a
very strange move
but it's an understandable move he's
trying to rush his pawn to h5 as early
as possible
i'm going to stop him in his tracks by
playing h5 this is not a necessary move
but i don't want to deal with this kind
of stuff thank you diaz chern
now if you look at this pawn on d4 very
carefully how can we apply more pressure
on this pawn
we can do it in one of two ways we can
do it directly
by attacking we can do it by removing
one of the defenders
of this pawn i.e the bishop on e3 both
ways are possible let's start by
developing our pieces right
let's start by going knight to c6 and
developing our pieces surgical taste
thank you for the prime and if he pushes
his pawn to d5 that then creates
weaknesses in the center which we can
occupy with our pieces that's not
something we should be afraid of
because our knight can whirl its way
around to e5 the nice central square
in the king's indian you want you have
to be comfortable with provoking
a lot of pawn moves which may look
intimidating but actually be bad thank
you skittle and this is a perfect
example
of one such move he he seems to occupy a
lot more of the center but now we turn
to the second method
of attacking the pawn on d4 by removing
the defender of the spawn look at this
bishop on e3 look at it carefully
can we try to remove this bishop from e3
we absolutely can that's why he
shouldn't have played h4 because now
this is a weak square we put our knight
there
he's in huge trouble already he's got to
move his bishop or he's got to defend it
but
the the end result of it is going to be
the same he's going to lose the d4 pawn
and with that pawn his entire position
is going to collapse very quickly that's
part of the appeal of the opening such
as the king's indian he prefers the
second option
now what should we take on d4 with the
bishop or the knight and don't rush to
give me the obvious answer here this is
where
you really want to apply yourself
we should take not with the knight
that's the tempting move
we should take with the bishop because
this is actually a skewer if his rook
moves we simply take his undefended
knight
now a case could be made that the bishop
is so strong
that we shouldn't even give it up for
the rook but
i would say that we should i mean an
exchange is in exchange he decides to
give away the knight
not a good call because this bishop is
going to be easily evacuated back to d4
and then back to its home on g7 this is
what they call the king's indian bishop
and it is a malicious bishop indeed but
before we
evacuate anything what can we do here to
win even more material
absolutely that square is going to be in
his nightmares the g4 square
is going to be in my opponents
nightmares he resigns and that was a
nice game a good introduction
to the king's indian okay um
nice nice nice one moment please
okay um so basically
basically the king's indian and a little
bit of chess history here
and i've already done this before but i
actually don't remember when was the
king's indian first played
the king's indian at least in the modern
formulation
was first played and i'm going to give
you guys a multiple choice
uh question here and i've already
i've already shared this piece of
information before so i'm going to give
you guys three choices
was the king's indian first played 50
years ago
approximately 100 years ago
150 years ago or 200 years ago
and this is the one time you guys are
allowed to spam
so enjoy it
okay a lot of you guys are getting it
actually i mean a lot of you guys are
getting it very close
uh the answer is a hundred and
so it was first played in the year 1851
which is about 170 years ago
and it was played extensively by a guy
named bonner g
and banerjee was a uh indian player
from the 1850s who was the first to play
the king's indian
in a match against john cochran a
character that we've already
encountered before who himself developed
many openings after
1855 it was played in 1879
by lewis powelson uh very one of the
leading players of the day
uh and i've made this sort of sermon
before but
you have to understand that back when
these people were around it was very
much
not commonplace to give up the center
like this okay so nowadays we think well
what's so impressive about this
random dude playing the king's indian
it's the fact that he was laughed at
when he played
this opening because back then it was
anathema
to simply relinquish
completely the control of the center so
it was quite impressive that these
players nonetheless decided to
experiment with it they didn't play it
perfectly
but they set the the groundwork for uh
you know we stand on the shoulders of
giants now we know how to play these
openings
but they were the first ones who took
the plunge okay
um so he played h4 which again is a
big mis well it's not a big mistake but
it sets them sets them up for failure
because it weakens the g4 square
the main move here is knight f3 simply
developing the pieces
because it's very important to support
the center you could play f4 here that's
the four pawns attack it's a very
dangerous opening for black
but it's also very hard to play for
white because often times he bites off
more than he can chew there is a queen's
indian as well
the queen's indian for those interested
and i've played the queen's indian many
times
is this opening right where you
fianchetto the other bishop the queen's
bishop
this is the king's indian this is now
some of you asked what wasn't this a
perk
a perk is like the cousin of the king's
indian and the difference between the
king's indian and the perk is that the
perk happens after one e4
in the king's indian white usually has a
pawn on c4 the openings can transpose
into each other
but that's the main difference so
uh generally in the king's indian
actually
you don't play knight c6 you play either
e5 contesting the pawn directly
or you play binoni style with c5
so the move knight c6 we allowed
ourselves to make
by and large because he already weakened
his position so if he goes d5
again he creates all these holes on in
his position
which we can occupy with our pieces um
the perk is a good opening yeah i've
played the perk but i don't recommend it
to beginners and now f4 was basically
the decisive mistake
we slam a knight into g4 we attack his
bishop if he moves the bishop then we
take this
juicy central pawn he decided to defend
his bishop and now he played bishop
takes d4 skewering
his rook to his night he should have at
least given up the exchange rather than
tonight but he's still in very big
trouble he's down
he's down a a an exchange in a pawn
now what if he went on to e5 uh at which
position
at one of your previous games you played
h4 well basically the difference is that
he's not developed
when you're not developed at all it
rarely is a good idea to send
your corner pawn in motion because that
simply creates more weak squares
and it's one of those things that you
know i always compare to like driving a
bus
right you can play h4 you'll even see
that some gms have played it but just
because gms have played a move doesn't
mean you should play it
because they've put a lot of thought
into it they've prepared it and it needs
to be played in a very specialized
fashion right you can't just even i
can't play the move h4 without
preparation because it's a very risky
move
okay um
thank you nine volts this seems too many
yeah
um if the pawns were protected perfectly
would be what is the big
difference between king's indian and
modern yeah the modern is e4 g6
again the modern usually transposes into
the perk
but it can also transpose into the
king's indian if white plays c4
narcoleptic work thank you for the prime
my friend
um any questions why don't i recommend
the perk to beginners
okay i'll i'll keep this brief because i
know people are looking forward to me
playing i'll do one more game latin and
blonde with a five tier one subs to the
community incredible stuff here
going on thank you so much latin and
blonde for another hype
five gifted subs incredible level of
support here as we approach
4 500 subs i can't believe it okay
sorry i'm pretty excited okay
so my theory of chess improvement and
please take this with a grain of salt
because i have a lot to learn in the
realm of teaching
uh you know there's every student
teaches me something i i get better i
make mistakes so
this isn't like a a theory that's been
graven in stone right uh it's just one
man's perspective
i'm not saying that i'm right this is
just my personal ex perspective born of
my experience
in my perspective is that people need to
learn and get a very very
steady handle on chess principles basic
chess principle
as boring as it may be right it's like
you watch you watch
michael phelps you know swim laps right
in the olympics and you want to jump
into the pool
and then some jerk named daniel nerds he
comes along and says well you need those
like sleeves you know
that that little kids have when they're
learning how to swim like i want to swim
with michael phelps but you can
understand i'm sure
that in order to swim like michael
phelps one day
you need to master the technique right
and playing
classical openings you can liken to
mastering the technique you have the
sleeves on
i still have the sleeves on i play e4 e5
there's nothing wrong with this opening
but when you play the perk you jump
right into like
white water rafting you know when you
barely know how to swim
and you know playing openings where you
give your opponent a big share of the
center as you guys have seen from my
games in the perk
is very difficult it requires
specialized knowledge of how to play
these positions
and so i don't really recommend these
openings to people normally before they
reach
you know 16 1700 give or take although
every player is different
hopefully that makes sense hey doctor
should we do one more
no the king's indian has not been
refuted
so rad broke off you have something a
little bit off because the king's indian
is currently considered one of the most
reputable openings
in existence it hasn't been refuted in
fact it's had a resurgence
in the last couple of years cremes thank
you for the prime so i'm not aware of
alpha zero refuting the king's indian
6 000 viewers let's go and let's
continue
and i'm not saying that because i'm
emotional i am emotionally attached to
the kings indian
let's play e5 let's put the training
sleeves back
on and he plays the ponciani now the
ponciani
is a dangerous opening uh and it is
something
even i haven't reviewed it very much and
uh the response that i'm gonna play is a
counter gambit actually let me think
about what i want to do here
um there are several ways to deal with
the ponciani in the ponciani the idea is
the white wants to of course go
d4 i am going to play a very aggressive
response to this move f5 i'm going to
counter strike in the center
before he gets a chance to play d4 now
he can still play d4
in fact i think that's his main move uh
but f5 is a very dangerous move
obviously it's a very dangerous move i'm
weakening my kim
i'm exposing my king but i'm banking on
the fact
that he has not developed a piece he's
moved upon
not only has he moved upon he's blocked
his own knight from coming out to c3
which i think lessens the immediate risk
of opening up my king now his queen
wants to come to h5
and do me quite a bit of damage so it's
very important now to develop quickly
knight f6 this is theory
i don't know this actually i'm
experimenting with this myself
now he goes bishop c4 so he's
threatening of course fork how should we
deal with this
are we already lost we're not lost but
how should we deal with this
we should go d5 and block that bishop
now bishop b5 i think is theory
goes bishop b3 which is a little bit
passive now this knight on e5
obviously uh i see the same thing that
you guys see which is this knight is
very annoying
now we shouldn't take this knight
because if we take this knight he takes
back and then if you if you follow this
you'll see that he puts a lot of
pressure on this d5 pawn so let's try to
force the trade on our own terms
and we can do that by developing our
bishop to d6 it's very good when you can
do many things at once
we develop a piece and we basically give
that knight a little nudge right can you
take c6 please
and what's gonna happen if he takes r
knight if he takes r knight then we take
with the fun
and as i've explained many times we
shouldn't think of this as a bad pawn
structure this is actually a good pawn
structure we have a pawn chain
just because the pawns are doubled
that's okay right
that's not the end of the world i know
what a lot of you guys are thinking
greek gift sacrifice but it actually
doesn't work
super important and after the game i'll
show why it doesn't actually work
instead of the greek gift we should
simply
develop our pieces with castles there's
a very important reason that the greek
gift sacrifice
doesn't work here now
just because the greek gift doesn't work
doesn't mean that we shouldn't attack
his game we absolutely should attack his
king
but in order to attack his king we have
to solve a couple problems
one of which is the fact that he's
spending our knight we really want to
get our knight to g4
the immediate thing that comes to mind
is h6 but what i don't want to allow is
his bishop to come to g3
and trade itself off for our bishop
which is one of our strongest attackers
so instead of forcibly removing the
bishop from the pin what should we do to
also try to employ or involve one of our
main pieces we should go queenie
this is a very typical idea in many
positions we get our queen to g6
uh we will dislodge the bishop and now
our knight can move as well
and we are spoiled for choice finally
guess what guys the greek gift sacrifice
finally works here and again worry not i
will explain all of this after the game
in detail
so everybody will understand exactly why
it works now
i wouldn't actually even do it in a game
but i'm going to demonstrate the greek
gift here
this is not as simple as it appears
white has several defensive resources
but where should the queen go
and this is the typical continuation of
the greek gift
i know arum this is crazy yeah let's get
queen over h2 we're not playing this to
attack the bishop we're playing this
move
to come out to h2 i don't think he has
any way to stop it other than giving up
his queen for our knight
that's obviously not a very feasible
option
all right he doesn't actually stop me
well that was well earned
okay um so
first of all loadrunner seven thank you
for the tier one
let's first talk some history now this
move c3
um is called the ponciani uh the
ponciani game
uh and as often happens in these
situations according to my research
ponciani never actually played it
ponciani i believe was a 19 it was an
18th century player who
simply advocated for it and
according to my research here the first
well this is really interesting
in the first ever game to feature the
ponciani
which is withers against williams two
british players
guess what williams actually played
thank you ivani pawnee
guess what move black played here this
is actually quite funny
maybe i'm a reincarnation of this person
he played the move f5
uh so actually i decided to play the
very same move
that this guy williams played who was
the first person to ever face the
panciani in a tournament game
so f5 is a very logical move that's how
they used to play back in the 18th
century was immediately again but
nowadays the main move is knight f6
thank you cal cow 6
and knight f6 leads to some really
interesting complications
white goes d4 obviously white center is
under a lot of fire there's this idea i
won't go into the theory
if you play e5 with black you should
definitely study the ponciani a little
bit
but this move five i think is one of the
better better defenses against the
ponzione even now
d4 by white now who won that game it was
a draw
now what happens can somebody tell me if
white takes on f5
why am i not simply blundering upon and
opening up my king what is going to be
the continuation here
and this is a very typical thing well d5
is not the best i think the best is to
go e4 immediately attacking this knight
the knight is nowhere good to go
if it goes to d4 we can capture it on
ruin white's pawn structure
and we we stake a big claim in the
center kind of like the schliemann and
the red lopez
so d4 uh take stakes
uh knight f6 developing our knight now
we blocked the bishop and now i think he
made a big mistake
bishop b5 here is more active because it
attacks c6
it probably forces us to develop our
bishop to d7
and he can take the bishop he has the
two bishops game he has the two bishops
now one interesting tidbit is that f5
was played i think
yes so it was played by julio basara
cuban grand master against hikaru
nakamura
in 2007 in the u.s championship
so hikaru was rated 26 58 back then
becerra actually won a very nice game
yukari surprised him with the ponciani
but sarah played f5
so this is a very dangerous move and the
hikaru game
actually continued oh so hikaru played
bishop b5 immediately he played bishop
b5 here
in order to prevent the develop the
deployment of the d-pawn
renoir 1977. and i actually was going to
mention this but i wasn't
100 sure um so anyways bishop b3 bishop
d6 dislodging the knight
now very important why does the greek
gift sacrifice not work
now there's a checklist of one
two three four items
okay that you have to go through kind of
like a pilot before landing
before you go for a greek gift sacrifice
and item number four
is what people always forget item number
one is obvious
is there a bishop that can sacrifice
itself on h2 and when i say h2
you can mirror this to to h7 all right
it's symmetrical
yes there is item number two is there a
knight
that can follow up with a check to the
king on g4 or g5
and is that square defended sometimes if
i didn't have a bishop on c8 i wouldn't
have been able to do that
because the queen would have been able
to take the knight right because
well uh here of course i can take item
number three
do you have a queen that can then move
out to h4
or h5 and combine with the knight and
the way that the creek gift sacrifice
happens
yes we do three out of three item number
four
after all of this happens does your
opponent
have the capacity to defend the diagonal
or the h2 square directly and this is
what people forget to check about
to check what can white do in this
position he can get his bishop out to f4
and guess what this bishop is guarding
h2 despite the imposing appearance of
these pieces
black actually doesn't have a follow-up
i don't have any pieces he's going to
get his bishop to g3 he's going to
stabilize
and he's going to be up a piece now
i can show you guys a million examples a
million examples
of people who have greek gifted
and then forgotten to check for item
number four and lost the game
in in a relatively uneventful fashion in
fact i'm going to find one such game for
you guys
here is a position which occurred in a
game between a player who is not famous
but probably like 2000 and irwin
livenowski i think he was an im
or an fm 23.75 and in this position
mr burnett played bishop takes h7 he
said
ladies and gentlemen great gift
sacrifice we got this guy
and he goes knight g5 now item number
two was circumvented because
here black can take the the knight but
what happens is that white plays hg
this is a very common thing in the greek
gift i've actually even talked about
this in a previous speedrun game
and in lieu of the night we have the
rook which basically achieves exactly
the same effect of threatening checkmate
on hha so this would be winning this
might be the most viewers i've ever had
so
again this is a big honor and thank you
everybody
now uh lipnowski calmly returned to ga
and and bernat was i'm sure quite
excited here what did he miss
it's electro thank you for the prime d m
d nine five eight four something to tiv
binny boom goes the dynamite bishop d3
and this is exactly item four you forgot
to check
queenie for check would do the same
thing technically but it would blunder
the queen
and this move is forgotten about all the
time white has simply no threats the
bishop is going to return to g6 and
white resigned
because he's simply down down a piece
okay so if this isn't like
real people don't miss this stuff they
do and that's why i'm
explaining it because it has real chess
applications that's a hard move to see
when you're calculating ahead
how do i find these games so quickly
well i'm using a search tool on
chessbase i can show that later
now here once again some people said
bishop takes h2 works
because we can play knight g4 exposing
the bishop
and then we can take the bishop 100 bits
thank you
what is it that we're missing here what
can white do
and and this is something i've seen
people fall for as well
the problem here is that our queen is
hanging which means that he now has the
license to take on g4
and if we take back he takes our queen
at the end of the day we're going to be
down a piece thank you e wells for the
sub
uh and that's not good now in a
situation like this
you might see wait a second both queens
are hanging which means we're looking
for a way to move our queen with check
we can do that but unfortunately he can
block the check with the screen and now
he ends up two pieces up
that's not good either okay 6k viewers
we've broken it
now here what is the difference why does
the
greek sacrifice work here well let's go
down the four items
do we have a bishop to sacrifice on h2
with we do
do we have a knight and is the g4 square
protected it is
do we have a queen to get to h5 yes we
do
item four can he defend the square with
his
bishop or his queen or his knight no he
cannot this square is protected by the
pawn
and most importantly this score is now
protected by our rook so just
logically speaking you can see the
difference between this great gift and
that great gift
any questions about the greek gift of
course he should have given up his queen
that was the best he could do
okay w zutely where do you live now
charlotte and cnn back home as of today
let's go with a sicilian
and the type of sicilian that i
recommend to players in the 17 1800
range is the accelerated dragon once
again
i will explain stuff after the game in
terms of the opening but in the
accelerated dragon you go for the
kingside fiance
a lot faster than you do in the regular
dragon that's why it's called the
accelerated
and you basically accelerate also your
development you develop all of your
pieces quickly
uh including your king so let's castle
this is all theory
and he falls into the oldest trick in
the book one of the great things about
the accelerated dragon
is the traps that are contained within
it
uh people often play the accelerated as
if it were the real dragon
not realizing that in this position
black is a very vicious trap
does anybody know this trap what should
black do in this position i will be
quite impressed
black is a very cool move here i will
explain this in
very great depth after the game but
anybody who plays the excited do you
guys know shark
shark knows it hallux thank you for the
gifted queen to b6 is the move
you guys might be looking this and
saying what are you doing you're putting
your queen
right under the line of fire of the
bishop what kind of trap is that
you're gonna trap your own queen but
this is actually a very dangerous move
white is already in trouble
if he doesn't know what to do he goes
queen to d2
now he's hoping for us to take b2 that's
actually not what we're going to do
what are we going to do does anybody
know the follow-up
the follow-up yam euro knight
takes e4 if you've noticed we've
sort of subtly put all this pressure on
his knight on d4
now we take on e4 we went upon and we
exposed the attack on d4
we now have three attackers he's got two
defenders we just need to decide what to
take on d4 with who can advise me in
this area
what should we capture on d4 with the
knight or the bishop
i'll explain everything after the game
guys not the night
you're falling for it if you take with
the knight you pin yourself
that would be very dangerous because
white would be able to castle and attack
our knight
pins very dangerous be careful about
them and we should actually take with
the queen this is all theory
if we take with a knight that knight is
defended only by the queen and he'll be
able to dislodge the queen by going
knight to d5 once again
i'll spell this out after the game so we
do accept an end game here
okay sometimes you just have to trade
queens that's part of the process
he refuses to trade queens
now let's not forget to complete our
development we're going to go to d6 in
order to open up the bishop
okay and again those of you are like
what are you doing i'll explain
everything after the game let's develop
our bishop he castles long okay
so now joe nathan thank you for the sub
we have a situation
with opposite side castling what does
that mean what does it tell us about
what we need to do when we have opposite
side castling we immediately need to
deploy
our pieces toward his king we have no
time to waste and as innovative panda
says
let's begin by putting our rook on sort
of a direct artery toward his king
what should we do now let's just start
pushing him let's start bringing our
pieces
into the game with as much pizzazz
as possible now one thing that we can do
let's not forget we have a nice outpost
for our knight right 95 is a nice move
because we open up the rook's potential
sacrifice on c3 which would
shatter the posit which would shatter
the pawns around his king this is a
no-brainer in the sicilian
this is an absolute no-brainer because
look at how weak his king is and look at
this bishop on e6
it's directed at the pawn on a2 so let's
not just grab the spawn mindlessly where
can we put our queen
and go for a greater prize than just
taking the pawn
ah let's take the i faked you guys out
we could have gone queen a4
but i'll explain after the game why uh
this is a better idea now we can go
queen a3 and attack the pawn
there was a reason that i that i
reconsidered going quinn a4
um and i also like trolling people and
faking them out and just being mean in
general
something i like to do okay um what
should we take on c4 with the bishop or
the knight a tricky question
well i know a lot of people are saying
take with a knight because that seems to
carry more possess but remember
something
the the queen and the and the queen and
the knight are the strongest attacking
tandem in chess
okay so oftentimes you want to gear
your moves toward leaving yourself with
a queen and a knight because when the
queen and the knight have your opponents
king in close quarters
they're just normally going to be more
skilled at delivering that crushing blow
than the queen and the bishop that's not
always the case but oftentimes it is
and i think that's going to be the case
here okay now if he goes queen c2 one
very important thing
do not forget about tactical basics in
the midst of an attack i see this
all the time people get fixated on
delivering checkmate you're in checkmate
mode
and you forget to check for stuff like
no pun intended for stuff like forks
okay who said we can't deliver a fork
girl 93
is going to win back the exchange we're
gonna get into the end game i know
that sounds lame but the reality is one
two three four five six seven
okay i did not major in math sorry and
he's got four so we are up
three pawns that's an elementary win if
we can adhere to basic endgame
principles
both one of which is to activate the
non-king pieces the other is to activate
the king itself
we're bringing it toward the center
let's defend the pawn we're gonna bring
it to e5
his rook is going to have absolutely no
chance
his kingdom here has fallen and as we
know in these end games
there's many ways to win them let's not
take on e4 let's not rush this move
because he's going to go rookie 2
and take on e7 so let's preliminarily
defend that pawn and maybe prepare the
move f5
why are we playing f5 what are we going
for here what's the most important thing
to do
in an endgame when you're up a million
pawns can somebody
spell it out to me concisely we created
a passer in fact we created two passers
in fact we created
three passers and trust me now we can
just close our eyes we can go on
autopilot
and we can just push them in fact we can
give one of them away in order to
promote another don't try to be greedy
with your past pawns
try to understand which which one of
them you're going to promote in the end
probably it's going to be the f bond
which means that we can lure the rook
into capturing d4 i didn't blunder this
pawn i lured it there
so that now this pawn can be the one to
promote it still has its neighbor
which means that if he goes rook d1
which he probably will he does we can go
e3 e2
and the pawns overwhelm the rook and we
promote the pawn in the end
okay i rushed that a little bit because
i was getting low on time but let me
explain everything after the game we're
actually going to make two queens
let's make two of them who says we can
make two queens
and let's get one of them here with your
permission guys i'm not going to explain
these moves
i think that they're relatively
understandable okay he didn't even take
our rook
this is going to be checkmate all three
pieces involved full team effort
and that's the game and what a
complicated game it was so let's go
through it with a fine tooth comb
now the difference between the
accelerated dragon and the main dragon
the main dragon
is this right you go d6 and you go g6 on
move five
and the accelerated you omit the move d6
instead choosing to go g6 immediately on
move 4.
what is the main advantage of the
accelerated over the main dragon
they both have their advantages over
each other in the accelerated you apply
immediate pressure on this knight on d4
right you don't waste any time going d6
but on the other hand this move d6 could
be very valuable because it opens up the
bishop el canto thank you for the parent
now let's go straight to the meat of it
what is this queen to b6 now let's do a
little bit of chess history first who
was the first person
to actually develop this trap i'm
actually checking that
the first person to have ever played
this move did it in the year
did it in the year 1958
oh how juicy is this
one of the people involved in falling
for this trap
is right here in this room and for once
this person was
on the white side of this trap thank you
waterboy928
this person is
this dashing gentleman here who is the
second from the left now it's pretty
small but you guys can probably make out
who it is
mr fisher mr fisher whose signature
is right here r fisher
and this is from the olympiad i think of
19
well xix i'm not sure which olympiad
this photo was taken in but it may have
very well been exactly the one
in which bobby fischer fell for this
trap in 1958
bobby fischer who was by that time
i believe he was like 16 years old or so
maybe somebody can correct me on this
now bobby fisher played a tournament in
poland in 1958
already he was on his way to become a gm
he played oscar pano
who is an argentinian grand master very
strong player i think he's still alive
pano also contributed to opening theory
and oscar pano
was the first person to have done this
this trap against
none other than bobby fischer how cool
is that and fisher actually responded
correctly and found the only path to
equality
now why is queen b6 good because we put
pressure on the knight
and we also attack the b2 pawn okay
remember that pins go both ways it's
like a two-way street i know that when
you look at this position optically
you see the fact that the queen is in
the bishop's crosshairs but remember
that white has gone f3
which leaves the bishop undefended and
this fact is crucial
because if the knight takes c6 what do
we do
what do we do here craig costa thank you
for the prime and knight f5 i'll get to
in a second
we play queen takes e3 and then we take
the knight on c6 now knight f5 is the
move that scares a lot of people because
that knight simultaneously defends the
bishop but enter the second point of
queen b6 we take b2
guess what here's one knight that's
under attack
here's two knights that are under attack
can white defend both of them at the
same time he
absolutely cannot okay
if he takes on g7 we take c3 we take c4
and to add insult to injury we're going
to actually win this other knight
so so that's how this kind of thing
works
okay uh so knight f5 is not possible now
what what
should white actually do here the only
way that white can equalize here
is actually to to go bishop b3 drop the
bishop back to lock in the queen's
attack of b2 and now go knight to d5
this is the only way for white to
equalize things get complicated here
i won't analyze this further you can
look at the fischer game
our opponent played queen d2 and now
knight takes e4
we win a pawn and our bishop now attacks
the knight on d4 so we're going to win
it back by taking the knight on d4
okay so takes bishop takes d4
and we are simply up a pawn why didn't
we take with a knight
because he castles and our knight is in
a whole lot of trouble right we have to
go e5 and that then creates a very big
weakness on the d5 square
now um badminton is cool you're
referencing a fischer rushevsky game
which was a slightly different opening
um and i could show that one as well but
that was in a different opening good
thinking though it was very
similar 24 thank you for the prime
now we move on to the attacking phase he
doesn't trade queens so we simply
complete our developments
we have a hype train on top of
everything else
okay um so we centralize our knight we
also threaten bishop to g4 which would
win the exchange
and fade back thank you for the prime
now here i originally wanted to go queen
a4 and attack a2
but i was a little bit concerned that
our opponent would evacuate his king
from the attacking zone and this is
actually i'll make a little lesson out
of this
be very careful when you're attacking
your opponent's king
that you're not allowing that king to
actually evacuate on its own two feet
okay that's a very typical narrative of
attacks that
don't work and i've seen this time and
time again
even grandmasters can forget that the
king itself can take matters into its
own hands
and escape an attack uh and and
and in the heat of the moment because
you have so many pieces in the attack
you simply forget about it
uh you just don't think about it and uh
and and that can happen in the snap of a
finger
i've actually had well i had a game
where i managed to pull that on one of
my opponent on my opponent once
and i can show you guys really really
quickly now this is an example of the
king
simply evacuating the attack now you
guys can see i'm playing black here this
is from 2007.
thank you wix vos for the tier one you
can see that my king is under a
a great deal of stress right my king is
being attacked let me just expand this
my king is being attacked
and guess what i did i just said let's
get out of there king of fate king e7
king d8
and now my king is perfectly fine in the
center
okay so literally just on its own two
feet
boom boom boom get out of there okay so
don't forget that the king can actually
evacuate the attacking zone on its own
two feet thank you oopsies [ __ ] for
the sub
uh and and there's many better examples
of this just that's just a quick one
right there
so that's why i didn't go queen a4
that's why i played queen takes e3 to
make sure
that the queen covers this evacu
evacuation route by the king
now we go queen a3 because now the king
cannot escape via c1
he has to give up more pawns and now we
simply
transform the advantage from an attack
to an extra exchange where he's gonna be
up three pawns in the end game
that end game is going to be very easy
does it make sense why i'm doing knight
e3
there is no checkmate here we could have
also gone rook c8 and tried to go for
the checkmate by bringing another
attacker in
but i judge that there was no need to do
that because we can simply transform the
position into an easy win
uh one very important thing what if he
tries queen d3 that's a tricky move
thank you channel n05 latim blonde
oh we're gonna get there now the point
of this move is that if we take his
queen he evacuates his rook what should
black do in this position
very nice queen to be for check escaping
first
check and then we take the rogue if he
goes rook to d3
what about this one a tricky question
for you guys
what should black do here
thank you latinum blonde i take c2 is
correct because that knight
simultaneously defends a3 so the tactics
work out for me
he's got to acquiesce and now we're
simply up to bonds we activate our rook
we activate our king we create a pass
pawn all by the book
we push our passers we give up one of
them to promote the other and we make
two queens
deliver the checkmate any questions
about this game so the accelerated
dragon is super tricky opening
and i highly recommend it to a wide
variety of players
[Music]